here it's in vladimir's
we all know the dangers that lurk
outside our gates
i want to do my sworn duty
i want to protect my best friend from
danger
and i want a life to call my own i would
never bet against you rose hathaway
you must prepare lisa for a new role as
the head of the dragonbear family and
rose she'll do her duty
i'm the royal princess that needs
protecting rose gives and gives and i
take and take but i can be a leader who
ruled not just for the royals but for
all citizens whether you wear the crown
or not you have the power to change
there's
things
strange happening
i think i can help you
christian is a non-starter for a lot of
people
i'll be disagree of course i want to put
you first
but i can't
you can either be guardian or friend not
both
what's the game plan you know me more of
a role with the punches kind of girl
the ruler is not just any monarch
leadership requires sacrifice for the
greater good
i need to fight
we need to fight
they must be willing to give everything
they have we deserve a better future
[Music]
she's my family
i would die for her
you